vous avez remarqué la rue aujourd'hui
les branchés mode sont partout de la
tête aux pieds il vise en plein dans
leur époque dans le contraste est la
distinction
veste larges pantalons étroits noir et
plus aux cheveux ras et mèche pendante
le banal et l'exceptionnel réunit la
vitrine de la culture actuelle
la mode jeunes c'est toujours et encore
le look cowboys jean bottes et suit une
affaire pas si américaine que cela force
n ou soir le cuir est omniprésent trait
d'union entre l'indispensable et le
superflu
il peut être érotique rustique raffiné
sophistiqué canaille
en tout cas en achetant des vêtements ou
des colifichets on prend montrer ce
qu'on est
ou ce que voudrait être on cherche un
plaisir on veut être bien dans sa peau
mais que faut-il penser d'un tel
déploiement de séduction
s'il n'a pas d'autre but que le
renouvellement de plus en plus rapide du
parc l'estimant terre pour faire tourner
la machine économique